talk about the title trap art because i  feel like  you're like you said you're like an  artist artist you could really do  anything  and and i feel like that's kind of a  dope title for  if you were to just kind of box in your  genre  give it a name yeah but trap in  in my generation is always thought when  you think of trap you think of like down  south traffic of course you think of  like  g-z-t exactly my version of trap is  like the west coast trap the sugar-free  the two shirts of the world  and you know what i'm saying stuff like  that and artistic side it's just  me being me that's where you get just me  being me i might  one track i may do something you know  i'm saying or go or stay standard you  never know would you go get with me